you know i don't think that the culture
wars are are fake i think the culture
wars are taking place the point that i'm
trying to make is that oftentimes
whatever the culture war is of that
moment it is manufactured as a
distraction a perfect example will be
you know critical race theory which is
not taught in elementary schools
critical race theory is a graduate level
uh curriculum
and the fact that it's turned into some
weird like oh we need to ban critical
race theory in elementary schools it's
ridiculous and a massive distraction
that i think is intentionally meant to
be a distraction from what people are
really feeling frustrated about the
precariousness of their lives of their
work lives uh the fact that people feel
overworked that they have no control
over the work that they're doing that
they feel alienated over the work that
they're doing these are very real issues
and i think that you know the fact that
it's really largely been ignored by both
the press and the very
political leaders who were elected to
represent them in the first place has
led to the anger that we're seeing
bubbling up both on the left and the
right ben i think you want to make a
couple comments i mean this will be a
very quick note i mean i obviously
disagree with you about critical race
theory and whether it is taught in the
public schools critical race theory
which i studied in law school it started
off as a legal theory but it has an
element of praxis and practice that was
meant to be implemented which is why it
is taught in education schools as well
and why in elementary school yes it very
boiled down i mean ibrahmax kennedy is
preaching a very boiled down version of
critical race theory and his book is
assigned in elementary schools and the
fact is that when you are having
elementary school students who are
having to check off boxes with regard to
their race and then explain to each
other whether they are historically
privileged or not in fourth or fifth
grade that's that's a very dumbed down
version of critical race there there's
sort of a game that gets played with
regard to legal theories that end up
being boiled down intersectionality is
another great example of this kimberly
crenshaw it's a very intelligent law
review article about intersectionality
and how you can be a member of more than
one minority group and be discriminated
against in a variety of ways and then
that is used as the basis for a much
broader move in american political life
and then as soon as you point that out
they say well that's not
intersectionality it's the original law
review article that's a bit of no true
scotsman games playing and so i i object
to that and look it is a relevant issue
when you have terry mcauliffe who's
running for governor of virginia
literally saying in open debate that it
should not be parents who are making
educational decisions for their children
it should be the people in education i
mean that that is a culture war issue
that i think is of key importance to
people who have kids right